Can a person take too much vitamin D? Yes, you can.
Matter of fact, it's hard to discern sometimes because some labs won't measure the total vitamin D.
They'll just say greater than 150 on your labs. So it's like, well, what do you mean?
Is it 160 or is it 600? Well, some labs don't give you the exact number beyond
a specific number, like 150. Now personally, under the belief that it would be good for somebody
with cancer to have a vitamin D level of 80 to 150. However, when you get vitamin D levels up
to 300 because you're taking 20,000 IUs a day and you have for the last five years and you don't have
VDR defects in your genes, you're absorbing a lot of vitamin D that you're taking and you could
have elevated vitamin D levels. That's why I suggest people get their vitamin D levels tested.
If it is beyond 200, I don't suggest you continue taking
oral vitamin D. So yes, I do think there can be dangers in too much vitamin D.
Is there any data that shows vitamin D toxicity? There's just a few papers in the literature
back from I think the 1980s where somebody was taking high dose vitamin D for a period of time and
they did have vitamin D toxicity. But anything can be too much of a good thing, can be a bad thing.
So yes, I do think that a person can get too much of anything. So vitamin D is one of those things.
So I don't take a person should be taking 25,000 IUs a vitamin D constantly without getting
their vitamin D levels checked. If you're taking 5,000 IUs a vitamin D on a daily basis, you're never
going to have too much vitamin D. It's the people that are taking 20 to 25 I've had talked to people
that were taking 50,000 IUs a vitamin D a day because they saw some Instagram video of somebody saying
that that was good for you. Well, anything is where you just got to be careful. There's
anybody could go on Instagram that isn't a practitioner or maybe a retired practitioner. They can say
all sorts of things that don't get them into trouble because they're not technically a practitioner.
They're not licensed any longer. So if somebody follows their advice via a video on Instagram,
they're not going to be held liable. But I think you're morally liable. That's what bothers me about
Instagram and this not because it seems like these people are just saying things in order to get
just hints and to get followers. And I think there's danger in that. They're going to bring that up
again and a quite other question that somebody has down here. So